l'autriche a entamé ce lundi son
déconfinement le troisième confinement
avait lui débuter fin décembre les
écoles et les musées ont rouvert tout
comme les magasins
bien sûr les gens doivent suivre les
règles sinon le confinement sera de
retour et je soupçonne que le prochain
confinement reviendra dans deux à trois
semaines
un peu de liberté retrouvée également ce
lundi aux pays bas fermé depuis la mi
décembre les écoles maternelles et
primaires néerlandaises ont accueilli
les élèves dans un contexte de baisse du
taux de contamination
nous sommes très heureux de revoir les
enfants et les parents et bien sûr nous
sommes toujours très prudent avec le
port des masques
il faut faire attention à tout mais nous
sommes très heureux d'accueillir à
nouveau
enfin un premier assouplissement des
règles anti qu'ovide drastiques en
vigueur jusqu'ici au danemark après cinq
semaines de télé-enseignement près de
trois cent mille élèves d'écoles
primaires sont retournés en classe ce
lundi je pense que cela signifie
beaucoup certainement un enfant plus
heureux et peut-être des parents plus
heureux aussi en semi confinement depuis
début décembre le danemark a vu les
restrictions se durcir face à la
multiplication des cas liés à la souche
mutante britannique un contexte
sanitaire qui explique pourquoi les
autres établissements scolaires restent
fermés ainsi que de nombreux autres
lieux tels que les commerces non
essentiels les bars et les restaurants
il est aussi interdit de se réunir à
plus de cinq personnes